president trump is traveling to a
handful of crucial battleground states
this week
in order to take some of the attention
away from the democrats
the president is in wisconsin right now
chief white house correspondent john
roberts has that story tonight good
evening john brandt evening to you
tradition has long held that the
opposing campaign goes dark for the week
that the party has its convention well
that tradition went out the window
back in 2016 and again this year a real
indication of just
how high the stakes are for president
trump
78 days we're going to win this state
we're going to
take back the white house they were
billed as remarks not
rallies so as not to invite criticism or
comparisons with the mega events of
2016.
today's audience may have been smaller
than four years ago but rhetorically
president trump's appearances were every
bit political rallies
this is going to be the most important
election in the history of our country
in mankato minneapolis and oshkosh
president trump showing he's out and
about while biden is at home
comparing and contrasting his policies
to maintain law and order
with democratic calls to defund police
as president my goal to restore
safety to our streets by contrast the
democrats are promising to elevate their
left wing
war on cops and to
bring it up to the white house in the
form of sleepy joe biden
on the economy the president charging
democrats would tank
gdp with four trillion dollars in tax
increases
president trump again promising a swift
bounce back from the coronavirus crisis
insisting his policies will lead to a
full recovery that's god
testing me said you know you did it once
and i said did i do a great job god i'm
the only one that could do it he said
that you shouldn't say
now we're gonna have you do it again
president trump also denying democratic
charges
he's trying to hobble the post office to
prevent massive mail-in voting
the post office has been a disaster for
many many decades
we want to strengthen the post office
make it good it lost
78 billion dollars over a relatively
short number of years if you look
amazon and all these companies that now
do it's a whole new business
they just drop a lot of it right into
the post office and we lose two and
three dollars every time we deliver a
package
the president repeating his favorite
meme on joe biden
betraying him as an unwitting puppet of
the far left
but elevating his attacks on
progressives
likening them to fascists replace
american freedom with left-wing fascism
left wing we're going left wing all the
way fascists
they are fascists some of them not all
of them but some of them but they're
getting closer and closer we have to win
this election
in 2016 president trump won wisconsin
lost minnesota by one and a half
points joe biden leading in both of
those states in the latest polls
but the polls are beginning to close
somewhat tomorrow the president is off
to arizona which democrats are eager to
flip
and then pennsylvania on thursday the
president determined during the
democratic convention
not to let a new single news not to let
a single news
cycle go unanswered let alone an entire
week
brett john roberts live on the north
lawn john thanks